changes have already been made to the
sweeping Republican tax overhaul
proposal Kevin Brady who chairs the
house tax writing committee has released
a revised version of the plan that would
lower the overall value of the proposal
rady also says President Trump wants the
tax bill to repeal the Obamacare
individual mandate the penalty for
Americans who fail to buy health
insurance repealing that mandate would
save the government about four hundred
billion dollars but it would also result
in lost insurance for up to fifteen
million americans here to talk about
that and everything else and boy there
is a lot in washington as shannon petit
peace White House correspondent for
Bloomberg News Shannon great to see you
let's first start with the Russia piece
we know about Paul Manafort George
papadopolis now we're hearing news that
Carter Paige may have had undisclosed
meetings with Russian officials how
concerned is the White House at this
moment well on the surface the White
House has played a very calm cool
attitude about all this there's nothing
here nothing to hide we're fully
cooperating there's obviously tensions
among the staff who are being
interviewed continuing into next week
there have already been a number of
interviews the White House is hoping
those interviews are wrapped up by
Thanksgiving that might be wishful
thinking but there are a lot of tensions
that come with that about who's talking
to who and not to mention the huge legal
bills they are starting to face as they
get called in front of Muller and
potentially congressional committees
meanwhile The Washington Post is
reporting that the president's longtime
bodyguard Keith Schiller is expected to
testify to the House Intelligence
Committee next week about this dossier
the about the president's trip to Moscow
in 2013 how concerned should be the
White has to be about that well other
than the president's family knowing is
closer to him than Keith Schiller
Keith Schiller is often the first person
he sees in the morning and the last
person he sees at night other than his
wife and I should say that's until
August when Schiller left at the White
House he is a bodyguard a body man he
has a confidante he's a friend and he
has been with the president step-by-step
through the campaign through his time as
presidency until he left in August and
through his rise as a businessman in a
reality TV star so he was in Moscow at
that Miss Universe pageant in the
dossier
he was sitting next to him on every
phone
call during the campaign so Keith
Schiller knows a lot but he is fiercely
loyal to the president so don't expect
him to be singing like a canary to
anybody anytime soon
I shan't an independent of the Russia
investigation the thing that is taking
up apparently a lot of bandwidth in the
White House is the fate of tax reform in
Congress how likely is this house
announced plan to fly in the Senate this
is gonna be a tough battle and I know
there's the members who have put this
bill together are trying to make it
sound like it'll be done by Christmas I
guess who knows anything is possible but
when I talk to people on the hill they
say if you thought health care was hard
wait till you see tax reform because tax
reform is touching every inch inspector
of the US economy there are enormous
special interests here there's division
within the Republican Party and of
course the Democrats are already this
week once they got their hands on this
bill you know picking at it and finding
weak spots where they can use it to
their advantage
meanwhile the Democrats appear to be
eating their own at this moment in time
what what exactly what are they what is
happening here I mean this is a party
already in disarray that's only causing
more internal dissension and this often
happens to the party that loses the
presidency
not to mention control of Congress we've
certainly seen turmoil in the Republican
Party but the Democratic Party is going
through a transformative moment where
they are going to have to figure out
what they stand for where they're going
and recruit really great candidates for
2018 if they want to have a chance
nothing is in the bag for them and
there's a lot of soul-searching going on
right now and for who the heart and soul
and the future and fate of the
Democratic Party is meanwhile we know
the president is embarking on an
extended trip to Asia what's the
expectation for that
Shannen foreign policy is obviously
going to be a big focus with North Korea
the white house is trying to use this as
a chance to show unity in the region
against North Korea that this just is in
a South Korea problem or Japan problem
something the entire region is taking
seriously there's also a big economic
piece to this the president earlier this
year pulled out of the trans-pacific
partnership this trade deal now he's got
to go in and make these bilateral
one-on-one trade deals with other
countries we have not seen much progress
on that so far he promised he'd be able
to get us a better deal so now the
Roberts gonna start meeting the road on
that mm-hmm
in terms of the rubber meeting the road
I mean is there an expectation that the
white house is going to return with it
or that the president is going to return
with anything when he gets back to
Washington there there are definitely
some deals that are trying to line up to
show which they do a lot of these trips
to show that there's some sort of
progress it was an interesting there was
a question in the press briefing the
other day about who will be leading
these talks yeah of course we have a US
Trade Representative where the White
House said well the president you know
he is the one who is our deal maker out
there which has been unusual usually
there is a more of a staff and more of a
group that works on these deals ahead of
time he's obviously very hands-on
president he fancies himself quite a
dealmaker so he's looking to do a lot of
these one-on-one and has good
relationships with Ave and she and China
well he wrote the book the art of the
deal we'll see what transpires and in
sunny peace with Bloomberg thanks for
your time Shannon